that sort of sort of space
back he's he's immediately like
let's celebrate like i want to take you
out and i'm like oh
how many how many dates have you guys
gone on one
okay yeah we went on one right before i
left that was our first first date is a
date
go ahead sorry so now we'll go i guess
on the second one
but he's kind of short he's only like
five nine
oh that's you're you're what like five
i'm five eight that's tall enough right
not really
you know manifesting a tall man one of
the other guys i'm talking to is six
foot seven
oh wow
yeah
and we'll be going out soon it's just a
matter of like scheduling we just
haven't been able to like
link on the schedules we both work a lot
mm-hmm
there's another guy who i just made this
whole take a tic-tac about who
was like all about me asking me out
calling me all these pet names my love
and all this [ __ ] and then we're talking
and i was like oh you have the vaccine
right and he was like no
i was like you're not vaccinated and you
want to go out with me i'm like i'm not
going out with you you're not vaccinated
what are you [ __ ] kissing you you're
not vaccinated i'm like
really oh i wouldn't care i don't care
in too many arenas where you have to be
vaccinated like i work at a yoga studio
where we're requiring proof of
vaccination that's where i am right now
holding all this laundry i don't know
all these music festivals where they're
requiring proof of vaccination and to me
it's so much deeper than just like do
you or don't you it's about that like i
don't want to have that debate with you
right like clearly
if we don't view it the same way we're
not in alignment
right
so would you not would you not date
someone that was different than you like
politically no i wouldn't what are what
are your standards like what are your
requirements for a guy
i mean politically i definitely want us
to have the same view you know i'm a
black woman right so i'm not gonna date
a white republican that would just be a
headache like why would we do that to
ourselves
okay same friends we wouldn't travel in
the same circles and we don't view this
the world the same way so i wanted to
use the world the same as me and even if
you're not black but you're white and
you like get and understand the black
struggle fine
um but yeah i definitely want them to
have the same political views as me
because it's just
why bother and having those arguments
okay i'm just gonna turn into a fight
later
yeah no so what like what else
um
[Music]
well they have to have a car this other
guy who didn't have a vaccine he didn't
have a car i was like how are you coming
to take me out you don't have a car you
know i'm not driving anywhere yeah
so that's like minimum requirement you
have to have a car
um i've also realized that i want
someone that has like some sort of
creative or like
job and entertainment like i have
um
you have to be very ambitious because i
am very ambitious i want to be able like
you know we'll spend our days or
whatever separately and then at the end
of the night i want us to be able to
come together and talk about all of the
exciting things that happen in each of
our lives right like okay this other guy
was like well i'm not rich i'm a regular
guy and i was like that's fine but like
i'm not a regular girl like
i'm i'm not so like
if you are going to date me like either
you got to be able to handle that or you
yourself also have to not be like
regular like i don't think
like just an average person like that is
boring
okay so
is there like a do you care okay would
you be cool with a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah
okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
you wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring i'm getting an eight
carat christian cut vintage engagement
ring if you make 45 000 a year it would
take what
four years no eight years to afford how
much
i don't know anything about ranks how
much how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
my ring has to sparkle from across the
street like you have to do that [ __ ]
it's gonna blind people well that's so
superficial that's like so superficial
but it's about so much more than that
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right i go to yoga with this girl
who has an eight carat diamond
engagement ring yeah the weed company
and drives an audi
so it's about more than just it's about
the fact that you can afford that okay
well i'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because i'm telling you
but not not in a good way not in a good
way i'm telling you like my dad would
but if my mom asked for that from my dad
my dad would have told her to go find a
new boyfriend because there was no way
in hell he was going to spend 200 000 on
an engagement ring and
that's no and that's a multi-millionaire
in the top half a percent who had 10
kids my mom never
he said he's built to the becoming that
he wasn't that originally right
he wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like like to me that's
like such an unwise investment to spend
200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my god no no
oh my god no
that's like i would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know really yeah like i know
for me like i told you like my my
status is going up like i just did a
music festival where i made 30 grand
over there in one weekend
like i need somebody who can be on that
level right but the problem is like guys
don't care about your money
right there
i i know but it doesn't like
you know like
i'm just i think you're gonna miss out
on a lot of guys with like this crew
like to me these are like crazy high
standards so
today i listened to my dating coach see
she said you do not get your expectation
you get your minimum standard
mm-hmm who is your dating coach married
yes because she has a baby and her
wedding ring is at least five carats
yeah
and her man is rich excuse me okay you
know he herself makes like 30 to 50
grand a month
coaching women in love
i mean good luck if that like works for
you i just like to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like i think like
guys are gonna hear that and be like no
no no you have to have the man who's
okay with me maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but i'm i'm just thinking like
like
i i know but those guys that are making
like
like that amount of money like
like i think they typically
want like the young like 21 22 year olds
i don't think so
maybe
what
i'm 30. so i'm not that old i'm actually
no i don't age to be wiped up by
somebody who's like in their 40s and
like ready to be serious and start
popping out babies a 21 year old unless
you're kylie jenner is realistically too
young to be like popping out kids
like you're too young
yeah i mean that's just i'm sorry the
200 000 like that's crazy to me
that's like
oh my gosh i cannot believe that's crazy
someone that can make that amount of
money in a shorter period of time like
somebody who would say a musical artist
right a musical producer somebody who's
in entertainment somebody who's on a tv
show somebody who does like concerts and
tours that amount of money
isn't
the same
to them you know what i mean
what do you what do you mean
like say i was dating somebody like uh
easy right okay he makes 150 000 minimum
per show minimal that's what he makes in
a show yeah so if he does a couple shows
the 200 grand to him he won't even feel
it
no but like this is something coming
from someone like i've been in a
relationship with a guy that was worth
over a million
like i but i would never in a million
years ask him to spend 200k on a rank
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like i'm not entitled to
his money i
i mean
here's the thing if i can afford it
myself
i will i would want you to be able to
get it for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah i guess like we kind of probably
have different like views on like
spending habits because to me i'm like i
would even if i had the money i would
never spend that on a ring
but i'm also not that much of a jewelry
person right so it's like you're not
gonna need to be buying me diamonds for
every anniversary or
jewelry all the time like get me my ring
and that's it i don't really need much
else
hi oh gosh sorry
oh hi nikki i just added you to it
who is that purposely not putting your
camera on
no i have to like connect it to the
thing hold on i've done like a youtube
live with her she's
oh well
in a minute
sorry
i can i can drop you if this is a bad
time i just thought i'd add you to the
chat
no just real quickly because we got
dinner and lamb and all this other good
stuff
listen
this i love this live this is
hilarious this i love you with the girls
asking for 300k diamond rings and
everything on this one
these guys are now saying that women hit
the wall at age 20. and you're talking
about the 200 000
they'll oh god
but you guys are both women they're both
women so you really don't know
like how would you know but like being
around is being just like a lot of these
men they seem like they're la la land
themselves
and it's like the people that they're
talking about is like who are you
meeting so as
two people are coming with completely
different expectations and like when you
were saying earlier you have pointed out
the person that was in the yoga class
she had a three hundred thousand dollar
ring the person your coach she has a
three hundred thousand dollar ring it
wasn't like base the reason the ring
that i have i wanted it because of the
fact that growing up some there's no
certain type of thing in my family that
that's what it was but it wasn't because
any of my friends had that ring i
couldn't care less what they had so no i
don't want it because they have it i
know i can have it because they have it
do you understand what i'm saying like i
understand oh
diamond engagement ring is within my
grasp because i've seen it in real life
i associate with people who have these
things they're in my circles of people
they're in my friend groups
and i know i can have it because i've
seen it not it's not that i want it
because they have it i want it and then
i've seen it i've seen validation of it
in my in front of my face
well i'm not saying that you you
shouldn't want it because i do know
people that they've dreamt about a
certain type of specific wedding since
they were children i on the other hand i
couldn't care less
so there was i i definitely understand
that and especially when it does come
time for people to get married where
people like oh why would you spend this
money why i'm like i don't care that's
that person's prerogative that's what
they want that's what they want so if
you're saying you see that because of
the fact that you see it on the everyday
person that you communicate with so you
knowing that it's something that's
accessible so if that's that thought
process
okay but
i don't know
i'm just saying like i think you're
looking for like a one percent guy which
is very rare and i think you're gonna
like
like you're gonna overlook a lot of guys
that literally make that amount amount
of money would like have that money to
spend but choose not to because their
values are to save money
like that's what i'm saying like you
would overlook like my dad in this
situation who's like
top half a percent but your dad also
getting your mom to pop out ten kids i'm
not trying to pop out
because my dad wanted her too
you're talking about height so it i
didn't even know i thought most guys
won't talk like over six foot
so then when the you know different
people were sharing oh well this is the
percent of these type of i didn't even
know that was the thing because i'm like
most guys i know pretty tall
now you're adding the height to two
hundred thousand dollar ring plus
i don't know girl
i know what the universe knows
well at least your options are open
you're not just trying to just outside
of the hype you're open to dating you
know every not everyone i was just
talking to this guy who doesn't even
have a headboard he has a bed and one
pillow and i said where's your headboard
he goes oh i'm just a regular guy i said
oh
i didn't say i don't want to talk to you
anymore i said okay
okay so okay so did i misunderstand
you're okay with like not getting that
stuff
like i i just thought like i thought you
said you need the 200k like would you
marry that guy
well i mean this is also the same guy
that doesn't have the vaccine so i
wouldn't even go out with him but
um
no here's the thing like the way i see
it in my head is that like by the time i
get there we will be in the place
to afford
those things and you like also you guys
like i the the circles that i run in the
people that i know like i meet very
influential people who can afford those
things all the time in my everyday life
i mean pearl you saw my apartment like
you saw where i live you know what i
mean like i live in my free building
where you have to make at least a
hundred thousand dollars a year just to
afford to live in a place where i live
right but i'm saying like to a guy like
money is nothing like men do not care
about your money so if money is nothing
they can afford my 200 000 engagement
ring
no that's that's not what i mean i mean
like money money money gives you no
value
so like i'm not more attractive to a guy
because i make more money like if
anything like they don't prefer it
because they like would prefer someone
with more free time to hang out with
them and like i'm gonna make a video
about that i think it's actually ba
you think that's bs yes
i rece after seeing the whole thing you
know the podcast that you were on and
seeing that whole job i'm sorry about
that you think but this is something
else
now that a lot of guys are saying that
they want traditional women traditional
women traditional women and then they
don't value the money and other stuff
i've now come up with a theory that the
only reason why they want these
traditional women that do not have money
is so that they can have the ability to
leave these women at will and have them
destitute because especially now with
the whole texas band of the abortion
laws and stuff and seeing these guys are
just like cheering thank god we can have
you barefoot and pregnant back in the
kitchen and not working anymore
i at first i thought that that money
thing didn't really matter but i'm
starting to realize no these guys just
want the ability to leave you high and
dry and then laugh in your face
girl i got
ain't nobody getting pregnant or having
any unwanted babies
new thing that i'm just like
what they really want i don't i don't
think so like because i don't i don't
think so i think like
like
like money just isn't like attractive to
them like they just don't like like when
we see an ambitious like driven man that
turns us on that does not turn a guy on
to like like i think they don't want
like a girl that's like bad with money i
think that's like a turn off i think
that like they don't want a girl that's
like
you know doesn't like his terrible
finances whatever but like i just don't
see guys like
being like oh my gosh that's so sexy
she's the ceo like the same way girls
are right like that's true
my ambition
i said the men that date me are
attracted to my ambition for sure
i would have agreed with you paul until
watching that podcast that you were on
and all these women that they're pushing
these traditional values on that could
barely even formulate a
complete sentence and that's why i
wanted to do the reaction with you on
there because these other girls who are
normally on there and they're like
pushing the whole thing that we don't
care about this we don't care about that
meanwhile these are just only fan girls
that you're trying to push these type of
values on i'm like this whole thing
makes no sense
well well that's the problem with fresh
they just bring on like the trashiest
girl and i said that on the podcast i
was like do you guys think you're in
like a little bit of a bubble
like i was like but i think that doesn't
they see women as though i don't think
they see women as like
actual functional human beings
okay
hello
hi
he was on earlier he said he wanted to
come back on
um
i
i totally disagree with the point of
um
what was it men
women um
are thinking that men
uh want women that um earn like a lot of
money or more money than
that's just simply not true you're hard
you're kind of low so can you say that
again
like
i said
i said um men don't men don't value uh
women that make a lot of money that's
it's not really a turn on for us guys so
how much money do you make sir
you got it
oh gosh
hello how much money oh you're back
okay
maybe it's maybe it's my device let me
let me switch on to a different device
what
should i make the man run away
[Music]
i think he was talking about my theory
about um i don't believe that because i
just think that they want to be able to
be the bread runners to leave these
women destitute
and begging because after the whole
thing um only fan thing so many guys are
so excited i can't wait till these women
fail and then they you know they're just
completely out and homeless and begging
for pieces of change outside he's like
jesus lord want you
calm down well no i think it's not that
i think like people don't enjoy like
seeing people cheat and when
so like in this example like these girls
are kind of cheating right they don't
really have any real skills they're just
like hot
sell their body on the internet and then
they get to drink
not hotness right
what
these girls they have to maintain that
hotness you work out these girls no
easy like skinny and pretty but other
ones like they have to work out they
have to do like you know a lot more than
i have to do to be able to take their
clothes off on the internet and have
people want to look at them
yeah but like
30k a month could could you find the
motivation to like take like
not eat as much like that's what i'm
going to do 30k a month not having to be
in the gym so i don't know i said i
could make that in a month not having to
be in a gym well i know but we're not
talking about you we're talking about
the only fans girls like that's that's
the topic like i think men
like are happy with their downfall
because you're watching these girls
cheat essentially and when because a guy
could never do that so when they say
like oh like they're in the streets
whatever like i mean usually like it's a
certain type of guy that's gonna like go
out of his way to comment that but i'm
saying like it's i would guess it's
because we're essentially watching them
cheat and when like
i'm at work and i'm gonna have to do
some other work so i'll if you're still
on later i'll come back but okay okay
yeah bye but that's also then if we're
saying that it's the same reason why
they would turn around and tell me that
i can't complain because of not having a
certain type of privilege and someone's
going to have a upper hand at anything
so then if we can then turn around and
say oh well you can't cry because you're
not societies whatever and you're not
this well then you can't cry because
you're a man and that woman got a
breakdown
in the bbl okay i know but we're not
talking about like we're like the the
whole point was we're saying like why do
these guys
like pray like are they excited for
these girls downfall like you know these
girls have to work at subway after only
fans closes i'm saying it's because
we're watching them essentially cheat
um i don't think it's because men want
to be the breadwinners or anything like
that i think like these guys are
irritated that girls can just take off
their clothes and have an easy life
but these are still the same men that
are saying that life isn't fair for any
other woman that complains about oh well
i don't look at this and i don't look
like that they'll turn around and say
well it's not my fault you're average
looking it's not my fault that you're a
different third and you have to suck it
up and say you know what you're right
what what do you mean i don't i don't
understand what you're saying
in regards to like these are the same
guys that are saying that these women
cheated yes they did the breast
augmentations and the bbl's to be able
to get them out okay
but then don't
but those guys also attention typically
not like relationship attention
but they're still getting the money but
the only also with that i can't then
turn around and say oh it's not fair
because i don't have blonde hair or i
don't have this feature and it doesn't
make me and then they'll turn around and
say okay well that's your business that
doesn't mean society and everyone needs
to see you as a preference so it's the
same way it's just like okay someone has
a
fair advantage over something so it's
like well okay the same way i have to be
okay with things the same way i don't
think i agree that's why i don't care
what the only fans models doing all i'm
saying is like i don't think it's these
men thinking hmm i want to be the
breadwinner i hope only fans models go
to subway like i don't i don't think
that's what it is
yeah to me that doesn't make any sense
um sorry what were you gonna you said
you wanted to come on oh you're talking
about money right
yeah
yeah essentially like yeah guys guys
really don't care about um
like money i mean it can be an asset but
i mean
generally speaking like
when um
if a guy like
does care about women's money it's it's
typically because
they don't they make little to no money
so it's like
if she's making
more than him then he's essentially
um
it that essentially is gonna
be an attractive attraction to him i'm
sorry i'm like super nervous
so if
if a woman is is wanting a guy that you
know
makes more than than her and she's
making a lot of money like say she's
like in the top
but 15
that's what 75 000
a year
um not
that's that's a small percentage that's
like not not that many guys make that i
don't even make that i wish i made that
but um
again it's like
and typically when you find guys like
that they they typically want something
they
they they pretty much want
um they typically
i don't want to say they don't go after
the average looking women but they
tend to expect a lot out of a woman so
well
that's what that's no i agree because
like what what is your money to a guy
that has money like it's nothing
i don't know i'm funny i'm going to
correlate this to a theory video and
it's going to be like because even like
he was just saying about oh if a guy
makes a certain type of money he cannot
get access to a third pack of looking
woman well most of the time if you're
looking on youtube these guys are
getting access to again women they
cannot even formulate a complete
sentence
but that's not
that's not necessarily true if we look
at like the top um
like the billionaires right like a lot
of those like even let's take like
donald trump billionaire right melania
trump like that woman speaks three
languages she was a model right but like
she definitely could articulate more
than a sentence
well i could have said more modern guys
those are the guys that clearly have
been around the block and no common
sense wise you do need someone that can
actually talk about different forms and
societies and stuff
right those are eight those are the
older gentlemen that actually have been
around and know what how you move around
circles these newer guys like again it's
just the idea of i
and then most of the time they're taking
they're moving the goal post
one minute you're saying that this is a
valuable person and the next minute is
someone else
so what what guys are you talking about
are you talking about like fresh and fit
not just them but just guys that kind of
like circulates around those type of um
those group of men and even with the
idea of money i don't even understand if
we're talking about that concept because
if you're not even getting married to
the person why would you even care who
makes what money
um that is that is about are you talking
about like girls
no as well sorry i went back to the
point that we were making early about um
the theory that i was talking about um
if they wanted to leave women to be
destitute if they're not making this
type of money but then the gentleman was
just being the guys don't care about
money and then i was pointing out why
are we talking about money if you're not
even marrying the person
well i think like like and you can
correct me as i'm wrong if i'm wrong as
a guy but like i don't think a guy minds
if a girl makes a lot of money i just
don't think like they're not attracted
to it like when a guy makes a lot of
money and is successful we are attracted
to that we want to like have sex with
that like that like ambition power
whatever it is
men don't feel like that towards women
like men aren't lined up to date oprah
for example
yeah and to add what you're saying um
uh
like we don't again we don't care about
your money it's okay if you know my um
if my girl like
makes a lot of money if she makes more
than more money than me it's just that
we don't want that feeding that into her
ego that she could you know lord it over
me that's that's what guys and that's
what i particularly i'm afraid of if you
make more money than me that's fine i
just i don't want you uh hovering that
over like uh because it's gonna be it's
gonna it's gonna
it's gonna um
it's gonna cause a lot of like the
vision in our relationship and most guys
don't want that have you had a woman
that's made more money than you and
she's been um holding it up
over your head
uh
no
so well why are you afraid of something
that's never even happened to you
well i because i've i've seen it happen
i've seen it happen on social media
like your actual pants oh
like one well actually one of my family
members i won't say who
because um i have one of my friends that
are watching but
one of my family members actually um
has um
pre she's pretty much the breadwinner
like like in her in her marriage with
her husband
and like even like
one of the most simplest tasks
like
they they had this super big fight over
like furniture
like a few years back and like it's just
i don't know if it makes sense but it's
like he he doesn't really have a job and
like she's pretty much the bread winner
you know she she pretty much pays for
everything
and so it's like
it's
it's frustrating in in her
in her like um situation
um being the brethren like him not
working if that i don't know if that
makes sense well if this isn't your
actual mom and dad where it's like okay
i actually have someone that i can pick
up the phone or i can see them as an
example and this is just like a random
family member and then like you just
said
she didn't she he doesn't even have a
job so based off of their marriage i'm
sure that he didn't just not have a job
overnight this is something that they
both had
decided that that's what they're going
to do so i've heard this um if she's
being disrespectful to that man that's
kind of something that they formulated
as their relationship
well i don't i think it's more of like
what for one i think you're allowed to
like develop a fear based on things
you've seen so i don't think it really
matters like how they're related to them
you know like my parents are married but
i'm still afraid of getting divorced
because i've seen relatives get divorced
um but like the second thing is
um
i think it's just like guys don't like
the attitude and the entitlement that
comes with like girls that make a lot of
money so it's not necessarily like
like there's some very sweet and like
feminine girls that make money but it's
the like i'm better than you attitude
which sometimes comes when girls make a
lot of money that i'm above a guy that
makes like i'm better than a guy that
doesn't make the same amount of money as
me like nothing to do with values not
who they are as a person but even like
when we were just listening like 200k
ring
like that's crazy like
that's insane to me